There’s recently been some pretty huge leaks
and rumors concerning Apple’s 2019 iPhones,
so we thought we’d round them all up so
you guys can get a good idea of what to expect
in September.
Let’s get started!
About a week ago, renders of a 2019 iPhone
11 with a triple-lens rear camera were leaked
by OnLeaks, but the implementation of the
camera seemed far from what would be designed
by Apple.
The report from Digin.in didn’t give any
reason for the triple-lens camera, but earlier
reports showed that Apple was interested in
Sony’s 3D camera time-of-flight technology,
which is able to map rooms in real-time for
augmented reality and increase camera autofocus
performance.
That sounds exciting and it totally seems
like something Apple would do, but that rear
camera design was awful.
Thankfully, a couple of days ago, CompareRaja
released exclusively leaked renders of a horizontally
stacked triple-lens camera.
Now this one looks more like what Apple would
actually release.
The interesting thing we see here is that
the flash is actually built into a ring around
the center lens, and I’m loving this idea.
Alternatively, Ben Geskin created renders
of the triple-lens rear camera in the same
position as the current iPhone XS, and that
may actually make more sense.
Looking at the renders, you’ll also notice
slightly thinner bezels on the display, so
I’ve got no reason to complain.
Just yesterday, more info was leaked about
the new iPhone 11.
CompareRaja noted that two of the three rear
sensors are 10 and 14 megapixels.
Details of the third sensor are still unknown.
The selfie camera was also noted to pack a
10-megapixel sensor which I’m really excited
about since there’s still a lot of room
to grow there.
Recent rumors from DigiTimes and Jean-Baptise
Su claimed that the 2019 iPhone 11 would switch
from a Lightning port to USB-C, but CompareRaja
seems to disagree.
They noted that the 2019 iPhone will still
pack a Lightning port, but we won’t know
for sure until September.
Either way, we expect this year’s iPhone
to come with the new 18W USB-C charger in
the box.
Concerning Face ID, Ming-Chi Kuo is predicting
that Apple will increase the power output
of the flood illuminator, which should make
Face ID more accurate.
There’s also a chance that we’ll be seeing
the implementation of Vein ID, which would
allow Face ID to scan the veins inside a users
face, making it even more secure, but we may
not see that until at least 2020.
Another thing we may not see this year is
5G data speeds, and I’m totally okay with
that.
4G LTE already supports download speeds much
faster than what even the iPhone XS is able
to achieve, due to cellular provider limitations.
As for the notch, Ben Geskin believes the
Infrared lens and front camera on 2019 iPhones
will be integrated into each other, making
the notch smaller than it currently is.
I, for one, wouldn’t mind this at all.
But what about the complete removal of the
notch altogether?
Now we most definitely shouldn’t expect
this until at least 2020, but there’s possibly
a way for the TrueDepth camera array to work
from beneath the display.
How?
Well, AMS, an Austrian company, recently launched
an optical sensor that works from underneath
an OLED display.
This type of technology can be utilized by
Apple to implement the Face ID sensors under
the display.
As for the camera itself, it could be hidden
by using transparent OLED technology, which
is already being used by TV manufacturers.
The OLED pixels above the camera lens would
simply be turned off whenever you open the
camera app or any other app that uses it.
And when it’s not in used, you’ll get
a full-face display.
Just don’t expect this for another couple
of years.
A report from Barclays analyst Blaine Curtis
said that the 2019 iPhones could feature WiFi
6, otherwise known as 802.11ax, which will
be anywhere from 4 to 10 times faster than
the existing 802.11ac.
To make it even better, it should increase
overall battery life due to a new feature
called wake time scheduling.
As for display technology, Apple could be
using Samsung’s Y-Octa OLED panel technology
in the 2019 iPhones.
This would integrate the touch-layer directly
into the OLED display, making it thinner and
cheaper to produce.
For this reason, we may see a complete switch
to OLED on all 2019 iPhone models, and as
for Touch ID, don’t expect it come back
anymore.
Ming-Chi Kuo says Face ID has become too accurate
and successful for us to need Touch ID anymore.
He also said that we shouldn’t expect better
waterproofing any time soon since IP68 is
already more than good enough for what most
users will need it for.
And there’s one last thing before we end
this video..
AirPower marketing material has been spotted
on a Malaysian site alongside the new iPhone
Smart Battery case.
This shows that Apple hasn’t abandoned AirPower,
and we’re likely to see a release sometime
in 2019.
So there you have it, there are all of the
2019 iPhone 11 leaks and rumors.
Comment below if I missed any, and be sure
to subscribe so you don’t miss out on more
videos like this one!